[Music]
well
guys do you in your own personal
opinions
do you think hooters is offensive
of course not yes she's a beautiful
woman really
just to say yes oh i mean once i go to
hooters
uh you're not too many too many chicken
wings you know just
i don't think the wings are as good as
everyone says i'm wrong
then that's pretty offensive too i don't
think like everyone your opinion is
offensive
i don't know i've been there once and uh
i i was not swayed with the wings you
get the buffalo wings
i don't remember this was a long time
ago i've never been there once
really you'd be a fan if you went there
not once have i ever stepped foot into
hooters
but just knowing about hooters knowing
its reputation
whatever in my own personal opinion i
would not
label hooters as offensive yeah the
staff is friendly
they're very they want to [ __ ] you from
the moment you walk in
and it's only if you're lucky and i am
very lucky to be blessed
uh and yeah so they they're really
attracted to you and uh
you know if you're lucky and uh yeah i
had a great time
so who could give me a truthful
depiction of
i've never been to hooters you've never
been a hooter yeah
but i don't know where the nearest one
is mine is blow
like are you there every weekend how
dare you brian's like no wait look when
you're when you're
in your early 20s and you're not in a
relationship
and you're looking for a good time you
want to watch some sports and then
just be nurtured by someone and then eat
some chicken wings you really do play up
the
they're pretty attentive yeah yeah
they're very hard love with you
if you're lucky if you're lucky like i
was um ryan yeah i feel like ryan's like
listen i've never been to hooters but i
do
use prostitutes
you know if it's anything like the
service that i get from the ladies then
yes
i would offensive why waste my time
no like seriously where where's the near
suitors are
that sounds cool as [ __ ] that does yeah
yeah because i know they have a casino
but i've never been there it's not like
[ __ ]
close it just got changed i do agree
with nelson the wings are hmm
oh so what's your impression of hooters
like when you walk in what do you like
what is your review
it just feels like a regular restaurant
but then like the waitresses just have
big boobs
should they all do can i just say what
did you expect because that's literally
how i would review them well
i don't know i just wanna i just knew
like what the branding of it was
and like i just didn't really seem very
phased by i was like okay cool this is
just like the style the restaurant
you know jess caldwell worked at hooters
right yeah that's all i know about her
it's not just big taylor
yeah well that's that's the only thing
on a resume
she's gonna watch this too the biggest
lie ever
but jess watches every single drinking
literally every single minute i don't
even know what you guys are talking
about right now
it's like you guys think i just
personally roasted her because i knew
she'd be watching that's
absurd oh okay wait she's watching this
yeah exactly what [ __ ]
i'm just kidding i love you jess anyway
so back to our so this story time to
beef up your resume
[Laughter]
stephen green so this child here
he was he was uh wearing this hooters
mask
to school since august and recently a
teacher of his
told him to take off the mask and he was
like but why it's a family restaurant
and then
the teacher was like oh you want to know
why then go ask the principal why and so
he goes to the principal's office that's
how the teacher responded yeah
oh [ __ ] that someone else can take care
of that what an immature way to [ __ ]
dress a [ __ ] problem like go ask your
dad
yeah i agree the most embarrassing thing
he's wearing too is michigan football
they didn't even address that by the
like come on like that's so offensive
like take that off how do you make that
out so fast
i noticed i just thought monsters
university
jim harbaugh hasn't done [ __ ] with your
program but
i guess that's not offensive he's like
the typical letter m though how do you
like
no that's the m yellow and dude this is
the monsters
isn't it no no no it's it also says
university
it's also the shitty football amp
anyway so uh okay so then the teacher
says
oh well if you really want to know go
ask the principal so then he goes and he
asks the principal
and then he's saying that the principal
told him to take it off
three times and he asked him why and
then he's like that's why i would tell
it any hooters waitress by the way
and then so he he said just take it off
so then the kid took it off and he had
to wear a different mask
he sneezed the kid's name is ian by the
way so then when ian
when ian's dad went to go ask them like
what the [ __ ]
what's the problem and then they were
saying that it had been deemed
offensive this mask has been deemed
offensive
and then the principal told ian
that it's inappropriate because it
expresses a woman's body
what what if you choose to think that
way
about it could be an owl yeah who says
they're they're hooters anymore dude
i know boobs tits i mean those are more
than the
jargon you're gonna say like there's
worse one like i remember in like middle
school in high school when they had like
like save the boobies [ __ ]
oh yeah so it's all the [ __ ] time
like i feel like that's even more
offensive
than that honkers is worth honkers
it is yeah just a giant masses
yeah like you think about it it's like
hooters is a restaurant whether or not
they're known for whatever the [ __ ] it's
like it's a restaurant it's a family
restaurant
if that said titties that many times i'd
be like yeah take it down
exactly take it down bro or maybe even
boobies
in i'll give you boobies yeah but
hooters come on
so if that's why it's made the news
because it's just like
it's just a weird hill to die on like
it's just a weird thing to have a
[ __ ] problem with that badly where it
was
especially the petty like oh gosh the
principal and the principal is just like
well
you know making a big stink about it
it's just like dude don't you have
better things to do man like
at least like educate them you know like
you guys are educating show them a
picture of jess caldwell and be like
listen it's not always like this
i love you jess i love you jess i'm just
doubling down on that
[Laughter]
no but you gotta see her booty though
no but anyway so then the dad was saying
he's like
how is this inappropriate he said i've
never viewed it as anything but a
restaurant
do we feel women's bodies are offensive
i don't know
i don't the principal told me that it
was inappropriate i said
i don't understand why it's
inappropriate there's nothing wrong with
that mask
so he's saying that he'll never stop
taking his family to hooters
and he says we do like the chicken wings
they have the best
chicken and the caesar style is not too
damn bad either
it does like how this changes into like
a support hooters like
it's really funny because everyone's
taking a hill to die on and killing the
dad
everywhere weird hills like yeah like
none of these hills
deserve dying like no matter what he's
like chili's to go yeah i think we're
still
to going
[Laughter]
because he could have i think he could
have reinforced his idea without having
to be like
this restaurant we are going to this
restaurant for the rest of our lives
[Laughter]
he's like now we're going for
thanksgiving and christmas that'll show
you principal
365 days a year inviting the principal
over for thanksgiving dinner at hooters
she accepts i thought this was going
like in a direction where he was like
and then he took the mask off and then
they suspended for not having a mask
oh yeah well i'll do it like catch 22
and be like gotcha [ __ ]
jeez i don't know i already saw this
story and i'm like
this is ridiculous yeah but even like
when you go to hooters like what the
girls are wearing there like it's not
even
close to what you'd see some girls
wearing out in public these days you
know what i mean it's like
like like hooters could actually use an
update with their
with their outfit you know actually be
honest
wishes porn clothing i think is too
revealing
mystery yeah you have like pasties and
[ __ ] oh yeah
i think the mystery of the hooters
clothing is way better
i don't know do you like it to be more
covered up but just enough to see a
little bit because then it's like a
little tantrum a little bit of curvature
the real estate ladies thing what i'm
sorry i fully get yes he loves he loves
real estate porn videos
oh oh i was confused i was just like hey
you want to buy the house let's close
this deal
let's have sex right now like it's those
videos but they're wearing very
professional attire right
and like you can cover up a woman so
much but you can still see the figure
and so i think it's like that
you can't hide the figure you know what
i'm saying oh cause this kind of
reminded me a little bit
of when i was i think i was in
third grade fourth grade something
around that
like elementary school and we were doing
this
performance on a stage like for the
whole school it was like a thing right
and my performance was to dance to that
song the
the stop in the name of the
people before you break my heart right
so the song i mean the shirt that i wore
that day it said
sexy on it my mom took me to school with
a shirt that said
sex i already i think i was like in
fourth grade
eight or nine yeah something that's uh
yeah
third third fourth grade i don't
remember but yeah and then the principal
took me off to the side i was like you
can't wear that
and i was like what what's wrong what
does sex even mean i don't even know
what sexy meant
oh actually wait third or fourth grade
you didn't know what sexy meant
no no i think i was younger and now that
i'm thinking about it i think she's in
preschool
mom got you a shirt that said sexy yeah
that's weird
right yeah that's really weird i this is
the first time i'm really trying to
dissect that whole scene your mom was
really progressive
aggressive woman i don't know i call
that progress
yeah but i do remember that and i
remember people being
like i remember walking into school and
then my like the teachers be like
and then like taking me off to the
principal and then my mom had to drive
to school
to bring me a new shirt i actually want
to ask her now like yeah what's going on
yeah be like yo what the [ __ ]
like why why did you get me that shirt
as you find and also what grade was i in
because i don't remember
but also if you're eight years old
where'd you find it eight year old shirt
this is sexy
oh no and it was also kind of like a
crop top too what
yeah i remember that i remember like my
belly was kind of shy as usual
this turned into a group therapy session
but i will say um after that like i i
think that has been the only
item of clothing that i had ever worn in
my childhood that was like
weird and offensive like that wasn't a
norm like i didn't wear
that's the most weird inoffensive thing
a sexy crop top
when you were nine yeah yeah yeah
apparently probably younger
yeah i think we're missing the context
apparently
so you're looking like one of the girls
from the cuties poster i was thinking
that too just now
like just now was it did i look like the
cutie because also i was like a
[ __ ] twig like i had zero meat on my
bones i was just
a skeleton hey that is sexy though no
don't say that no don't don't do it
don't do it
can i get a little left is this like the
running gag of the day i get a little
bit
how old was i because i do remember
having a thought at the age of six years
old i love you thank you
that i was like but i do remember asking
myself like wait am i sexy
but for a bad reason it's dark oh which
i talked about on the big move podcast
if you guys want to check that out
anyway shout outs
we can cut oh okay i was like
how far are we going with that
[Music]
you